welcome to bananamores i'm so excited to
watch this next performer light up
the bananamore stage get ready for
comedy greatness
okay well i guess i'm here in the in my
own home this is good this is cool
i love comedy i love this industry uh
okay
well i just been inside like everybody
else you know
uh i don't want to equate it to prison
but i've just been in here doing prison
stuff i've just been doing push-ups
and reading books you know feeling real
bad for the dudes who write
the part of the book before the numbers
start i feel really bad for that dude
you know just feels like a rough a rough
gig to get asked to co-write a book
and then you find out you're in the part
with uh with all the
the letters you know they're not even
they're not even numbers they're roman
numerals that's that seems so
unfair you don't even get regular
numbers you know
that's like if you get if you get asked
to open for a huge comedian
like if i to equate it to my own
experience if if i did a show with like
dave chappelle then they bring him out
on stage and they're like hey everybody
you ready for dave chappelle audience
like whoa yeah
yeah all right give it up for this dude
that's what the
beginning part of the book feels like i
feel like all of black history is
written in the beginning part of that
book nobody reads that
part just being alone with my own
thoughts you know
thinking too much you know just been
sitting here exploring myself thinking
about
my i didn't know uh my my sexuality
before this but now
you know now i'm now i'm asking all the
questions
you know i took an online quiz that said
i was bisexual i was like i was just
trying to find out my hogwarts house so
i want to know
what that means that ravenclaw i guess
that's ravenclaw
you know
i can't even get over how much talent
this person
has kind of unfair